A CT scan on Monday showed that the cancer has grown and spread.
Sometimes I am unable to keep my supplements down.
Are there any other alternative forms
or additional supplements that may be taken
to help slow the cancer growth?
So yeah, we should set up a time to talk
because it's, you know, this supplements,
I don't know how long you've been taking the supplements.
Definitely, if you have trouble keeping supplements
down in the form that you're taking,
I think you're, I'm assuming that you're talking about
the pill form, maybe you're throwing them up
or it's hard to get them down to open them up
and put them in a smoothie, maybe in order.
Sometimes again, like that other question,
you can just be irritated from the capsule itself.
So open up the capsule.
If it's, you're safe to open up any capsule
unless it's a time-release supplement.
And it would say that on the bottom, on the bottle.
And there's not that many time-release supplements
that we are recommending to people.
But if it's not a time-release supplement,
you could open up the capsule and put it in a smoothie
or put it in a drink and drink it down.
Typically, if you put it in a liquid that isn't smoothie
or something like that, it might stick to the sides
and you're really not getting much of it down.
But so putting it in a smoothie and drinking this smoothie
over the course of the day is probably the best way
to get that in.
Are there alternative forms?
We've had some people that were not eating anything,
maybe even had a feeding tube.
So we had to use an all-liquid supplement diet.
Lots of times the liquids will be in a tincture.
They're not extremely tasteful.
But if you have a feeding tube, you're not tasting them.
But if you're drinking them still by mouth,
you're tasting them, and that can make your nausea.
So that does become more difficult.
I would suggest, oh, try opening them up,
putting them in a smoothie and sipping the smoothie down
might be the best choice to begin with.